now we're gonna talk about
King and pawn and games and there are
some positions that you absolutely have
to know because some positions are at
theoretical position which means a
certain position when you look at it you
already know the ending it's gonna be
their win-loss or a drop so and in king
upon end games they're quite specific so
you can calculate it until the end so
I'm gonna give some basic positions from
the beginning and then they're gonna get
more complicated but the theoretical
position so I hope I don't end up the
class everyone knows them so let's start
with this position oops
why to move so if you're raising your
hand I'm expecting you to give me a line
don't just give me your one move and
then expect me to tell you opponent oh
so you have to calculate a line okay so
why do you want to put your King here
five
okay so why do you want to do this okay
so when Kings are standing like this in
front of each other what is this called
yeah so what is opposition
okay so opposition is when Kings are in
front of each other and there's an odd
number of square between them so in this
position there is no opposition because
there's two squares between them that's
an even number so to have an opposition
that means the Kings are in front of
each other and it's your opponent's turn
so yes it's better to give up opposition
because so here here if the King goes to
c5 why do we want to get opposition
because how are we going to Queen this
pawn am i which way is my king going a
three or a four a four
yes not okay a four so the king has to
go back so again one move that wins the
game oh yeah is it time to push the pawn
do we want to push the pawn good
so again King this before the King goes
let's say here so our opponent gave up
opposition so which way are we going
see five looking v7 not yet King be 567
you don't you don't need to push your
phone you'll have time to push your pawn
king is oops King a6 okay so who knows
this position this is what this is a
theoretical position one of the position
I was talking about is this a winner I
draw
it's a win why of course we're white it
does does it matter how smooth it is so
does it or not so this is one of the
positions there is a theoretical win for
white so remember this if your King is
on a sixth rank in front of the pawn
except for the rook pawns route pawns
are different so if your King is on the
sixth rank in front of the pockets of
win it doesn't matter whether your pawn
is it doesn't matter whose turn it is
it's always a winner so if it's blacks
turn now I can push my pawn in this
position if it's White's turn it's a win
if it's blacks turn it's also win so if
it's White's turn I mean so if it's
blacks turn it's simple a 7 because a
what I do
oh sorry it's not yeah ok in this
position if it's black to move whichever
way the King bows you got the other way
and then you push your pot if it's if
it's whites turn who can't tell me the
win someone who hasn't said anything yet
it's it's pretty simple calculation very
straightforward c6
and then you clean your pond but let me
go back to this position
let me give something even simpler
blob to move we know a drum okay what's
the move that draws right so why do you
want to go why do you want to go to date
exactly so you're kind of passing the
move to your opponent so wherever your
opponent goes now you get our position
Kings are in front of each other it's
your opponent's turn so this is another
important position you absolutely have
to know so if King goes here now you
lose you lost the game
okay so let's move on to
okay so tell me what happens if it's
White's turn and what happens if it's
blacks turn
okay I watching
if it's whites turn who has opposition
luck so what's gonna happen okay who
someone tell me the drum what
okay I'm asking him to let him god right
remember you have to follow your
opponent's king if you go in the
opposite direction again you're gonna
lose
so King g7 so I have to push my pawn and
then
I think this so King if we opponent
those King beard what would you do
right remember six right in front of the
pond and you know it's a win so here you
don't even have to worry about you don't
have to wander you don't have to doubt
yourself you know it's a win that's why
it's good to know this position so the
King goes to d7 when white power has to
push the pawn and then the drying move
is where can go t7 there's a pawn so yep
three moves well for most
we're eight so you don't want to go to
eat because when you go to eat now I got
our position and now it's your turn so
you have to move over and now I'm going
to clean my pond
so you have to go to d8 so in this
position it's your turn so so far you
were good the last walk this position
remember very well this position I've
only moved a trust again any other game
loses the game and the other move loses
the game okay but let's go back to this
position
what if it's blacks turn yeah oh let me
change
Oh
okay let's see dude
so can you
right and now your pawn is going because
King is seven and the best thing is
these are gonna be your next remove
spawn here here and here and your King
protects all those squares so you're
just gonna Quinn your pawn
okay let's try something a little more
complicated white to move so this is a
little tricky because it's a corner pawn
so the King might be still made it yeah
so the good thing is here you have two
extra pawn so the good thing about
having a lot of extra material is you
can give some of it back so the problem
is if you want to bring your King to
push this pawn what's gonna happen tell
me so now we're giving up one of our
ponds and we don't want to give up this
one because it's always almost quitting
but King f6 and in this position whose
move does it have to be for this to be a
draw black but now we push our pawn
remove in the game why to move
you have an extra bishop but what is
your opponent trying to do yeah if your
opponent takes your pawn it's a drum
so what is the first move we have to
look at we have to stop our opponent
from playing King stink c4 I'm taking
the pawn so what's the move that stops
that there's only one move that started
I mean everyone has to come up with this
move even if you think it's not a good
most a move that pan stops incoming to
c4 yeah right so this is your only
chance to win the game and this is one
of the most important things you always
have to ask yourself what am i opponent
trying to do because if you make a
careless move then it's a draw game you
have an extra bishop on the pot and you
don't win okay Bishop d5 so again your
point wants to take your pawn so what's
your move what
very good okay so let me see if you can
win this position so I go back so what's
your next move okay and now you have to
make a very important move something I
talked about in the beginning 15 minutes
ago opposition
yeah an important games this is a very
important concept we don't move your
pants unless you know that you're going
to win the game because a lot of times
those pawn moves are gonna matter at the
end you can move your pawn later your
pawns not going anywhere so if first you
have to make sure your pumpkin Queen you
clear the path where your pot and then
you push it so King here and then
continue
so your opponent gave up opposition so
which way is your king going
not fight your king when his King went
this way your King has to go exactly
this is because you're trying to Queen
this pawn okay let's say the King
neither the King goes back so guys
remember there's a rule will learn if
the King is on a six-string
right the night disposition you already
know to win King on the sixth ring in
front of the pawn and it's a win
so King here now King goes
very good
and now you Quinn your fun very good so
this rule of course doesn't apply to the
rook pawn because rook pawns are very
dry and and the reason and the reason is
when your King comes here when your King
comes here I don't have the extra space
on the right to go right so I have to
play here and it's just a drop for rule
pawns as long as your King gets in front
of it it's a drum way to move
but this one is a little challenging
I know my pawn is under attack can you
capture it
yeah in the back
yeah good
what's your move okay no okay does
anyone else have an answer so someone
says kingi for someone says King F for
it's the only one more words good can
get first so what's wrong with King F
for what is black going to them good
King Day v king F 3 and then can you
continue no why not
they tried to cool Queen your pawn so
where should your King go your King has
to help your pond C for C you can do it
can get to now
qingxue 3 or pushed upon Kingston 3
kingdom 1 and now one more important
move yeah go ahead King D 3 and
whichever way the pawn goes I mean the
King goes you got the other way okay so
going back to the initial position so
King effort doesn't work so someone else
suggested King before what's the purpose
of this move yeah yeah good you told me
the move right because when we took on
f4 right away we allowed the King come
back from the other side so your king is
shouldering you so King you form so
whichever way the King goes you take
that pawn and you stay in the square of
the pawn that's anyone know the role of
this everyone at the rule of the square
is there anyone who does another roll of
the square and the one ever raises their
hand so no answer so what's the square
of this d4 pawn
if you don't know the rule of the square
raise your hand and I'll explain it okay
the rule of the square okay so the rule
of the squares so we draw a square from
where the pawn is to where the pawn is
going to promote so we count one two
three four does everyone know what a
square is yes okay it's a good start and
then we count 1 2 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
so this is the square of the pond so if
you have a pond that's going to a queen
you come and if your opponent's king is
in a square that means it's going to
catch the pond so you draw the square
and you see if their pond if the king is
in the square if the king is not in
squid and you know you'll Queen your
pond and also if you're trying to stop
your opponent's pawn you draw the square
and you see if you can catch it because
if you're not in the squid and you're
not going to be able to catch it so now
when you do this you're in the square of
the pond also you can you can also draw
a diagonal and draw the square like this
so now I'm in the square right because
this is the square of the pond and I'm
right there ok so so let me go over this
again so remember this position so in
king f4 so remember this position so in
this position is blocked to move but in
this position let's say I push my pawn
same position now whose turn is it it's
White's move so what is white going to
do king D - right right so the websocket
up
okay so we're getting the same position
but it's your turn instead of it being
your opponent's turn so this one little
move makes a difference so because if
when you play King you for what happens
to your opponent's position it doesn't
have a good move right either he has to
go yeah give up the opposition you get
the pawn and then you get the other pawn
or here's to push the pawn and now you
save the move so look at this again so
you take the pawn if you take the pawn
your opponent plays here this position
his chair but then when you play King e4
and then he gives up the pond same
position it's your turn so you were able
to save a move and save the game and
when it comes and when it comes to this
pawn in games this is very very
important every move makes a difference
because it always comes down to a matter
of one move because in a lot of
positions we say if it's your turn you
win your opponent's turn it's a draw so
it's very important for you to be able
to count this move